good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight it is Friday so we are
thrilled to be able to open the show
tonight with some rare good news that
doesn't happen very often and when it
does we celebrate
one of the main problems with the US
government is that there's no way to
know exactly what it's doing because
you're not allowed to know more than a
billion Federal documents a billion have
been declared classified and that means
they're off limits to you and all other
ordinary American citizens who don't
work for the government you're not
allowed to see them despite the fact
they belong to you
now no matter what you may have heard
the point of the system is not to
protect the country from foreign
adversaries under the bite
Administration we don't even bother to
do that anymore no the point of this
system is to take power from the voters
and the officials they elect and hand
that power to the permanent bureaucracy
in Washington
it's infuriating and over time it is
dangerous but for once we can report
some meaningful pushback against this
regime of secrecy and deceit
Kevin McCarthy of California became
speaker of the house last week last
Friday and in one of his first big
policy changes he is pledging to let
Americans see quote all that happened at
the U.S Capitol on January 6 2021 and
that means finally releasing the roughly
14 000 hours of surveillance footage
from that day that as of tonight remain
hidden watch this
yeah I think the public should see what
has happened all day I've watched what
Nancy Pelosi did where she politicized
it where for the first time in the
history as a speaker not allowing the
minority to appoint to a committee to
pick and choose we watched the
politicization of this I think the
American public should actually see all
what happened instead of a report that's
written for a political basis and I
think the answer we're looking through
that I want to be very thoughtful about
it but yes I'm engaged to do that
well yeah after two full years after a
highly publicized and highly politicized
Congressional committee after endless
grandstanding in the media after
unprecedented political crackdowns after
nearly 1 000 arrests after all of that
Americans yes they do have a right to
know what actually happened on January
6th that's what Kevin McCarthy said
who could argue otherwise what's the
counter argument
well there is one and Democrats have
been making it in court and that's why
the footage from that day is still
hidden here's an actual quote from an
actual brief filed in an actual federal
court by an actual left-wing U.S
attorney called Channing Phillips quote
National Security interests could be
harmed by the disclosure of the sealed
CCTV videos from the capitol once the
capabilities of a U.S capital interior
surveillance camera including its
position and whether it pans tilts or
zooms is disclosed to the public via the
release of a single video from that
camera the cat is out of the bag
so that's it right there you can't know
whether the capital's surveillance
cameras pan tilt or Zoom
and if you do know America is in peril
it's completely absurd every human
movement in the United States capital is
recorded by cameras and you already knew
that because the same is true in
virtually every public building in the
Western Hemisphere that is not a secret
and of course it's not the secret the
Democrats fear you might learn if you
saw the tape
they're probably a lot more concerned
about whether you'll discover how many
law enforcement agents actively helped
January 6 protesters enter the building
that day
some of them definitely did we know that
for a fact because we have the tape
watch
police are squabbling with protesters oh
there we go
[Applause]
and they just reached the capitol again
so you saw the barricades come down in
front of the Capitol in some cases it
was not actually the police who took
them down but we still don't know the
identity of the people who did why don't
we
well Julie Kelly is just reported on a
remarkable moment in the ongoing trial
of a man called Richard Barnett Barnett
is the man photographed with his feet
famously on Nancy Pelosi's desks on
January 6th
under cross-examination for Barnett's
defense lawyer this week a U.S Capitol
Police Commander called karneshia
Mendoza
admitted that unidentified but
apparently highly trained agent Prophet
provocateurs were leading the crowd that
day here's the exchange the defense
attorney asks quote would it be fair to
say that at least some of the leading
edges of that crowd they contained bad
people provocateurs is that fair
Mendoza's response quote it's fair
Mendoza went on to confirm that these
provocateurs were quote highly trained
violent people who worked together and
coordinate together
well that's a remarkable admission but
who were these people
under oath the director of the FBI has
refused to deny that these provocateurs
were working with federal law
enforcement
indeed Christopher Ray of the FBI has
refused to confirm or deny that FBI
agents dressed as Trump supporters and
breached the capital watch this did you
have confidential human sources dressed
as Trump's supporters inside the capitol
on January to 6 prior to the doors being
opened again I had to be very careful it
should be a no can you not tell the
American people no we did not have
confidential human sources dressed as
Trump's supporters positioned inside the
capitol
you should not read anything into my
has expired
well that's just completely outrageous
first it seems very obvious the FBI did
have confidential sources dressed as
Trump supporters inside the capital
but the fact is we have As Americans
have an absolute right to know
how many FBI agents or informants
participated in the January 6 rights why
can't we know
there's no good reason
FBI director Christopher Ray wants to
keep the surveillance footage hidden so
we can't know
again the real secret here is not
whether the cameras in the capital pan
tilt or Zoom it's ridiculous
the real secret is what really happened
there so for two years the Department of
Justice has fought the release of this
footage
but still some of that footage has
emerged take a look at this tape it was
obtained by BuzzFeed he was released
only after a federal judge rejected the
doj's claim that this particular footage
needed to stay secret on quote National
Security grounds National Security
grounds the footage covers a 15-minute
period on January 6th from 2 25 pm to 2
40 PM eastern time now that's right in
the middle of the so-called insurrection
for context 2 26 PM is around when Mike
Pence then the vice president was
evacuated from the capitol these are
images from a surveillance camera at the
Senate wing of the complex and they show
people calmly walking around taking
pictures not much of a riot
now that's relevant because the doj is
charging some of the people who enter
the capital around this time probably
including some of the people in those
frames with endangering the safety of
Mike Pence
they're saying the capital itself was a
restricted area because Mike Pence was
present
but it does not appear from that footage
that it's true
where exactly was Mike Pence at the time
people are doing jail time as a result
of assumptions about that question but
the rest of us can verify it because the
surveillance footage is still classified
for national security reasons
we should see it
that footage might also show when
exactly Capital police officers begin
CPR on Roseanne Boylan one Trump
supporter who died that day and that
would be important to know as well for
her family and for the rest of us
we might also learn about why one
capitol hill police officer on January 6
the man called Khalid Johnson was
wearing a Maga hat as he seemed to
coordinate with some of the protesters
that footage was shot by journalist Fort
Fisher you're seeing an image of it on
your screen right now
and maybe we'll learn more about the
Chewbacca guy the guy in the Viking hat
his activities during January 6th he's
the man now serving almost four years
behind bars for declining a police
officer's half-hearted request that he
take the party elsewhere
hey hey
man glad to see you guys you guys
Patriots look at this guy he's got
covered in blood God bless you yes
you're good sir you need medical
attention I'm good thank you all right
I got shot in the face
I got shot in the face with some kind of
plastic bullet any chance I could get
you guys to leave the Senate Wing Way
well I've been making sure they ain't
disrespecting the place okay I just want
to let you guys know this is like the
synchronous place
more than half of all murders in the
United States are not solved at this
point because law enforcement including
federal law enforcement can get its act
together sufficient to solve those
murders and that guy has had his life
destroyed and is spending 41 months in
prison
why did he do something we're not aware
of the surveillance footage would show
us
and answer that question
but big picture if you don't want
another January 6th if you want to avoid
another Riot like that you'd want as
much of the footage to come out as
possible instead our government has been
using the information blackout it claims
is necessary for National Security in
order to do what they usually do under
the cover of classification law and
that's lie to us
Joe Biden just claimed on camera that
right-wing insurrections racist killed a
capitol police officer called William
Evans William Evans of course was
murdered at a checkpoint by supporter of
the Nation of Islam
three months after January 6 while
they're still cordoning off the capitol
because threats these by these sick
insurrectionists
continued to
be profligated on the internet
again all America saw what happened
what officer Evans was killed defending
the checkpoint it had to go through to
get up to the Capitol
because of these god-awful sick threats
evil thrives in secrecy that used to be
obvious to all Americans
we have a right to know
and moreover transparency is the only
solution
and it looks like we're going to get
some and that's thanks to the new
speaker Kevin McCarthy and to the small
group of Republicans who pushed him in
that direction Matt Gates of Florida is
one of them subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight